bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo jet lag ma vi spiego
sono tornato ieri sera dal texas questo
video esce domenica però lo sto
registrando di venerdì non ha dormito un
cazzo show jet lag nell'anima il jetlag
sarebbe quando non dormi per due giorni
perché devi prendere l'aereo più o meno
e sto registrando happy meals in queste
fottute condizioni il freddo youtube è
semplice se morisse il criceto di
diarrea la spruzzo proprio tutti ragazzi
e benvenuti a questo video sono file già
oggi facciamo e piduista dormienti
perché possa dormendo in piedi però
vabbè dai pre shooting facciamo il primo
l'altra gassino stando in texas si
vedono in texas e in america si vedono
un miliardo e mezzo di i personaggi di
happy with in giro quelli che stanno per
poco
mi piace il menu devo fare option ma
meramente ma com'è possibile fanno ai
soci le opzioni non ma se io legge
disattivati si disattivano sul serio
expert mode all'attivo dopo dai facciamo
play missione una descrizione by a
sparare imparare come si sparano al
cuore e fucili che veri bello all the
space to shoot
vabbè ma e lo sto già mirando cioè
cazzola è semplice lo fa così che è
bello difficile questo gioco anche o
anche muove no vabbè ma è fighissimo che
hanno fatto a fare una roba del genere
su è più equa proprio professional level
fa vj coyote creek si chiama st zona
fantastico devo prendere questa mission
perche del continuo ma che cazzo di
gioco devo uccidere il tipo col cappello
blu già scritto a questo quindi finora
le posizioni da rapper minchia bango
filthy senso proprio ieri ha ucciso un
uomo con questo pugno
sono forte missione passiva avere chiama
che cazzo di gioco di merda e fatevi
provare le cose le opzioni questa expert
mode facendo in expert mode almeno di
bra il fucile
si vabbè mafiosa il parkinson madonna
che schifo madonna che più schifo ancora
minchia frate radar è diventato c'è
parkinson rivali propri social parkinson
amica un'ora e mezza e questo me la
prendo
ciò è fatta non so come va bene ci siamo
ragazzi allora drag companies io devo
uccidere uno che fa le droghe che
sarebbe questo qui è l'unico che l'unico
cristiano che c'è questo ripensare a
quello che questo tutti uguali sti tizi
sono tutti i neri non per razzismo sono
proprio neri o fai nel mission
fantastico serial killer devo uccidere
il serial killer e distruggere prima la
videocamera perché sennò la videocamera
mi riprende che sta uccidendo un serial
killer che dovrebbe essere una cosa
positiva
le videocamere vincolano mamme tipo
metal gear che ovvio che la videocamera
sta guardando proprio il tipo ciò lo
stava punta di faccia lui sapeva che lo
avrei ucciso quindi si è messo davanti
alla videocamera abello lezzi mai vlog
da un'altra parte alla prossima volta
accoglie achievement all'occhio
perfectionist ragazzi modalità esperto
c'è neanche gli sniper veri dessì your
la testa la tua fortuna guardava che
culo è io sono fortunato famoso la mia
fortuna quando 3d adventure ragazzi o
che stanno ancora banco le adventures
quelle in gardaland sono così l'anno
pompate così tanto figo ma scherzava fa
buca gare sa bene nel si ma lei che se
sei in 3d e io sono in 2d ti devi far
figo è per l'amore di dio io i livelli
in tre linee più east ragazzi non li
capisco perché non capisco dove devo
toccare poi qua lo tocco già no infatti
vedi non capisco le proporzioni l'ha mai
detto nessuno che se non stronza [ __ ] 9
lame
ecco ti sta bene brutta [ __ ]
ragazzi tanto mi faceva cagare quindi
vedono in porta facciamo album run degli
arpioni mi piacciono lo sapete tutti gli
arpioni corto li odio a vita dio mio
ecco cos'è qui in america non ci sono
gli arpioni però
sta cosa qua non l'avreste mai detto è
però in compenso c'è un sacco di gente
vestita come il padre di uk e non so
perché che si prende alpini nel collo
ditemi se non è la vittoria più sfigati
abbia mai fatto salvo un titolo random
vabbè york flat giorgio anche se in
ritardo sei ubriaco non sobria oggi a
baby baby mila tassone gli ubriachi e
non è la stanza che sta girando sono io
che la vedo girare devo uscire da da
dietro permesso
perché se babbo natale a caso papa a
carissimo babbo stai bene stai in groppa
a un triangolo comfort mentre ricevo
confermi sia aperta questa cosa che
cazzo ne live ma va trovato il profilo
di un utente a caso sarà un'illuminata
acquista o noleggia star wars il
risveglio della forza o da vida primi
test forma bau versi come sono bravo in
inglese
salve dobbiamo andare a morire da
qualche parte signore 9 spendono capito
quindi devo prendere stimolo e lo vedevo
colpire un pene al contrario mi è uscito
dal deretano è normale è tranquillo ho
trovato delle gambe in compenso sto
palleggiando con una gamba sola mentre
tengo due gambe sto palleggiando con una
gamba cosa non avete capito di questa
frase jump jump attack pixel attacco in
salto cipro stai calmo cibo di stare
calmo ma calmo sono vivo ma cos'è
cos'era va perché non mi richiama
impossibile per ma veramente
oddio sono io sono vivo prendi questo
pavé dai lo rifaccio posso già che non
dovevo per fare questa cosa per l'inter
già che non vincerò mai più
[Musica]
bravissimo bravissimo a maledizione rock
swing purple che cazzo mi significa che
purple jangle viola ce l'ha col vino la
lega senza motivo va bene aspetta 4
secondi perché 432 no 44 secondi è il
numero perfetto di secondi
come il numero di lupoli nelle birre
sono né 3 esplode my little war amici
non so parlare di che sarà jetlag ma non
so spiccicare una parola my little war
version update oddio così sono quei
livelli tipo dove sono tutti i minuscoli
a caso poi cazzaghese mortacci sua mi ha
fatto paura per una che bisogno
uccidesse ma è veloce sin jack in your
gen che gigante potente 99 per cento in
posti come facciamo questo credo che sia
la morte per un imposti mall più bella
che io abbia mai fatto c'è veramente
geniale ma magari zio figure di merda
così no che dici che siamo al 98esimo
episodio sempre fatti bene gli importi
parliamo al centesimo episodio senza
fare figure di merda è ecco dai dai zio
possibile cioè la prima volta nella mia
vita che mi trovi difficoltà con un i
costi ball ma l'abbiamo a questa l'ho
vinta è cieco come questo vino questa
vita almeno questa cazzo se so due ore
che sosto livello ragazzi passiamo ai
miei livelli visto che ormai siamo
arrivati al top dice versus jazz my
channel name is bruce forza favi avai
classi dicendo ai bomber mi sa che non
va bene ci prova in nulla mente nulla
più nulla ancora più nulla nukak in casa
propria il cazzo ha fatto sto livello
gioca mai
no non ci gioca minecraft e poi ai sei
rendendo conto era scritto
sbagliatissimo non guardare la scritta
ma chi stai guardando che anzi no guts
proprio dai frate dai frantini vittorie
l'ultima dai board capitana mio figlio
inutile senti frate io no non ho ben
capito con che criterio hai fatto sto
livello ma non so se riesco a finire
impossibile sono rotti i [ __ ]
vedreste fondo non si rompe i [ __ ]
mi sono rotti i [ __ ] ma vj goes to
the city fa dalla campagna alla città
con trappole mortali fra un the country
side to the city guide il liceo vista
cosa ripeterò all'infinito sanno
scrivere più in inglese che in italiano
come è possibile
è un livello sonoro e per ciechi devo
tenere chiusi gli occhi
ok se sarò là ho vinto io devo andare in
teoria ok slow slow zio non ci vado
perché se no devo totale muoia no no
vado slovo qualcosa mi dice che sono
ancora operativo ritornando lo sto
andando
oddio tipo e ti è incredibile del cazzo
files aver quale motivo 6 tornati gli
aggiunto natalini
grazie sparisce arrivo sono mica come
come faccio a essere vivo bellissimo 9
lega bellissimo come faccio a essere
vivo mai non è possibile mai dove vado
non davanti non è il geniale rega non
c'è la fine però è stato bello no come
cazzo fate a scendere dal cielo vivo è
impossibile farla cazzoli concluso
vivido spero che vi sia piaciuto il
prossimo sarà il 99º 99 episodi wow
vado a suicidarmi comunque gasoli spero
che vide vi sia piaciuto e cosa e se vi
è piaciuta sono un commento è un mi
piace anche a pacciani facebook come
video trattare iscrizione sono serviti
scatti ci vediamo al prossimo video
bella ragazza